Donald Trump has been tweeting attacks on
protesters from the White House for days while
offering up a suggestion that the military
go in and use more force against protesters.
Meanwhile, Democratic presidential candidate
Joe Biden has been meeting with protesters.
He gave a very good speech yesterday about
the state of the race as well as police relations
in this country.
And we now have Democratic Senator Elizabeth
Warren joining the protest marches yesterday,
marching with her husband and her absolutely
delightful dog, a golden retriever named Bailey.
Here is Warren marching, of course, with a
mask asked by a protester.
Why is Donald Trump bringing in the military?
Warren says because he's wrong.
People are protesting peacefully.
Check it out.
It is a little bit difficult to understand
all of the audio because people are wearing
masks, but I think you're going to get the
gist of it.
Why does it go wrong?
His wife says, yes, our people are test Elizabeth
Warren not being shy about what is going on.
She tweeted on Monday, quote, The president
of the United States teargassed peaceful protesters
in order to clear the way for a useless photo
op outside the White House just after vowing
to activate the military against our own people,
lives and democracy are in danger.
Danger.
I like this.
OK.
She's a senator.
She's not going to say everything you or I
would necessarily say, but she's being strong
and clear here.
And how about Bailey, the dog at the protest?
It really just doesn't get better than a nice
dog joining a movement for sanity and reason.
So what's going on with Warren as V.P.?
You all know, last week I interviewed Congressman
Roe Karna and he said he believes Warren is
the best choice for V.P.
Joe Biden is increasingly getting pressure
not to pick Elizabeth Warren from different
camps.
OK, there are some people who don't want Warren
to be the V.P. because they don't like her
wealth tax and they don't want her wealth
tax to be made into the law.
The reality is that Elizabeth Warren's wealth
tax is very unlikely to be made into the law,
even if Elizabeth Warren is vice president.
Please understand that it's not even clear.
Joe Biden supports that.
There's another contingent that wants Joe
Biden to choose a black vice president.
Now, remember, Joe Biden already committed
to choosing a female vice president.
Yesterday on the bonus show, we talked about
the call for Joe Biden now to pick a black
female vice president.
I believe that the top choices in terms of
who's likely to get it for a black female
V.P. would be Kamala Harris and maybe Val
Demings.
Now, Kamala Harris is hugely problematic because
of her actions as California attorney general.
Given what's going on right now with the protests,
it strikes me as maybe a bad idea to pick
Kamala Harris if in two months the protests
have died down, maybe it's something that
would be less problematic from a P.R. perspective,
although her track record as California A.G.
is not good.
Val Demings, on the other hand, would be an
interesting choice.
She's a congresswoman from Florida with a
list.
Florida, Georgia now.
I believe it's Florida with a law enforcement
background.
And I think that that would be a very interesting
pick.
Now, there are people talking about Nina Turner
or Stacey Abrams.
I know not everybody in my audience knows
who they are.
I don't see it as even remotely likely that
Joe Biden picks Nina Turner or Stacey Abrams.
So let me know your thoughts.
Who do you think Biden is most likely to select
vs. who would you like Joe Biden to select?
Interested in hearing from you?
You can let me know on Twitter at David Pakman